sí sin duda y también de paso el futuro
del partido conservador que sabemos
viene de crisis en crisis pero lo cierto
Es que no tiene otra opción después
justamente toda esa controversia que
duró semanas y semanas con el plan
financiero presentado por listras en
septiembre Lo cierto es que este nuevo
plan financiero que quiere recuperar la
economía se resume en más impuestos y en
acabar con el gasto público recortarlo
esto para acabar con la brecha de 55 mil
millones de libras esterlinas el
gobierno de sunat además se ha
presentado hoy como el partido y el
gobierno que puede tomar las decisiones
difíciles que son requeridas en este
momento justamente para sacar a flote la
economía Pero además Está tratando de
recuperar la credibilidad y la autoridad
frente a los mercados internacionales
que estuvieron en crisis en varias y que
llevaron a la caída más histórica en la
libra esterlina frente al dólar
americano Luisa también como pueden
afectar a los británicos los recortes al
gasto público que prevé este plan de
emergencia
en esta presentación que hizo el
ministro de finanzas Jeremy en el
parlamento dijo que se comprometía a
proteger a los más vulnerables a las
familias que están viviendo días Muy
complejos con la inflación disparada que
llaman en 11-1 punto por ciento las más
altas en 41 años pero también al mismo
tiempo Aumentar los impuestos de los más
ricos pero lo cierto Es que las personas
en las calles en los bancos de alimentos
se preguntan si con estos recortes que
se harán esos días difíciles que vienen
para el país en el gasto público
terminarán impactando los beneficios que
reciben Jeremy Hunt ha dicho que por
ejemplo las personas más vulnerables
recibirán estos beneficios recibirán
hasta 1350
libras esterlinas al mes también se
protegerán las pensiones esta subirán
con la inflación y también se
comprometió a dar más recursos al
sistema de salud pública en eches y
también a las escuelas pero lo cierto es
que los partidos de oposición critican
Este plan porque dicen que no va a
ayudar a que las familias británicas
dejen de ser más pobres o por el
contrario puedan tratar de salir a flote
en esta crisis creciente en el costo de
vida y ahora con la contracción de la
economía